we continue to follow that breaking news
this massive fire on the northeast side
of town Clark County firefighters
battling it it's near lamb and Cheyenne
Brian yeah we see a little bit of the
dissipation of the smoke there at the
bottom of your screen but still going
relatively strong eight news now
reporter Mary Jane beliesza now joining
us live near the fire Mary Jane with the
very latest
seen here this fire is off of lamb and
Cheyenne I'm going to move aside so you
can see what's happening right now we're
still working to gather details and we
do have fire Crews on the scene working
to put out this fire including North Las
Vegas fire department you can see there
are about three ladder Crews working to
put out these Flames that smoke looks to
be dying down but they are working hard
to put it out again we are still
learning the cause of this fire can see
plenty of that water next to me as well
it's all dripping down on the streets
we're going to show you where all that
water is headed down again we are still
working to figure out more information
but it seems like with this area it's in
a lot of the industrial zones right now
there is a love store next to us there's
also the Sinclair gas station next to us
this area has been blocked off by a
fence so it is hard to see the vantage
point but you can still get an idea of
that smoke there right now it is black
and building up still working once again
to confirm all this information and
where and what exactly what happened
with this fire you can already see it's
behind that yellow building here where
where there is a sign it does say Las
Vegas wholesale but it's still hard to
determine what exactly that building is
and what exactly caused this fire again
we will stay on the scene here for you
live reporting from lamb and Cheyenne
Mary Jane beliesza 8 News Now